Kim Kardashian and Kanye West welcome
baby number four having kids is just
there's no way to describe it but it's a
lot it's like the best way I know how to
describe it
back in January Kim confirmed to be
couple was expecting a baby boy via
surrogacy
the reality star had difficult
pregnancies with five-year-old daughter
North and three year old son Saint and
welcomed one-year-old Chicago the a'
surrogacy last january anyone that says
or thinks it's just the easy way out
is completely wrong yeah i think it's so
much harder to go through it this way
cuz you're not really in control i hated
being pregnant right and i never thought
i'd ever I thought this was gonna be so
easy and you know but I still even in
how much I hated it if I could do it
myself I would have preferred that so
that's a little like that inner struggle
is kind of hard but I'm just rolling
with it and it is what it is the last
time we sat down you had mentioned that
the thing that really stressed you out
about surrogacy was like the lack of
control because you are such a boss and
you're in control is it different this
time
um it's a different experience for sure
I think every situation is different I
love my surrogate we have a really good
relationship I know that she I really
trust her and I definitely see like the
first time that I went through it I was
a little bit more anxious now you know
maybe texting more and calling more and
I feel like my surrogate this time
around really is such a protecting
person and I really trust that in her so
I feel really calm and at ease I don't
know if it's like a fourth kid thing
right or just we've been through the
surrogacy thing before you just get a
little bit more calm as as we go
you